don dickerson joins us now john good to
see you you know listen cassidy
hutchinson gave us a lot to process
yesterday i couldn't turn it off
yesterday what was your big takeaway as
you watched
the biggest takeaway gail is uh
the idea that president trump knew um
that he was basically that there was
overwhelming evidence that this was
going to be a violent day uh that he was
getting information from all different
corners and then specifically that he
was told uh at the start of the day very
early in the day that there were people
armed in the crowd
and that each time he was given one of
these warnings he didn't do what a
president is supposed to do which is
make things safer but he made things
less safe that he created more
destabilization and that
it could have been far more violent on
that day than it was
well the former president has weighed in
scott touched on it briefly he says
she's a very cassidy is very negative
person he barely knows her
she's phony she's a leaker she's very
angry
do you have any reason from what you
heard yesterday are you hearing any
reason to question her credibility
well she was under oath
she also testified at a time where
there's a high cost to testifying in the
old script of american politics if
you're a hero and you come forward and
you stand up in a moment of testing of
your character everybody rallies around
and and calls you a hero at the current
moment particularly in republican
politics you are ostracized you are
threatened with violence uh so it is
there's a high penalty to testifying so
under oath uh under that um
that the violent conditions all of which
suggests uh that it means um
there's a there's a weight on telling
the truth but
recollections can vary and it's the
committee's job and all of our job to
make sure that whatever cassidy
hutchinson said
lines up with what with other testimony
this has been a long series of of
hearings there will be many more and
there are other people who can cooperate
some of whom who haven't come forward
who can nail this down because you can
imagine it might be hard to remember the
precision of that day although she had
notes and so forth else uh when it was
pretty hectic inside the white house
john as we learn more details about what
happened on that day many americans are
sitting at home wondering what's next so
can this new testimony open up a case
for the justice department to charge
former president trump with a crime
if they were to do so the key thing to
focus on from yesterday's testimony was
the idea that president trump knew
that there were uh guns in the crowd he
knew that violence was more likely even
than we had previously thought and he
pushed and pushed and pushed uh to whip
up the mob uh and push to make it easier
for the mob to uh to do its work uh
there's also some evidence in the
testimony that there was a closer
connection between the white house and
and the proud boys and these other
groups that came to washington at the
president's uh
request he called everybody to
washington for this for this rally um
that there was a closer connection
between the white house and those who
came to do mayhem
those would be two avenues worth
pursuing if they were trying to build a
case against the president
now i would imagine people are searching
cassidy hutchinson's trash cans and
digging up in her background right now
she gave us a lot to unpack yesterday
john thank you very much